this is more power to Logan Paul but he
gets on there and like so what's next
for you he calls out Rey Mysterio yeah
Chuck please I know that was excuse me
sir check please I'm out no no I'm I'm
done watching it but KSI Tommy Fury's up
next I'm good he just called out Rey
Mysterio after a boxing fight but again
Logan's like dude this is my path I can
jump here I can jump there so again kids
you can do whatever you want to do
whatever this proves you When someone
tells you no matter what tax bracket
your parents are in no matter what
situation you're in not when I say this
proves you can do whatever you want to
do this is the living example and this
is a good thing for Logan Paul to get in
there and fight Dylan danis in a boxing
match advertise and have his prime there
and then call out Rey Mysterio who's a
WWE guy you can do whatever you want to
do and this is a good thing